[Music]
next Lionel Shriver writes a column this
week about a decision by the Texan
Supreme Court to ban so-called gender
affirm and care what is gender affirming
care and why does Lionel think it was a
good idea to ban it she joins me now
rewrite in your column this week about a
decision by the Supreme Court in Texas
can you tell us about that
well there have been a number of
Republican dominated legislatures that
have passed laws Banning so-called
gender affirming care for minors it's
not making it illegal to get
uh sex change operations and medical
treatment for adults It's All About Kids
and there have been states such as
Florida where the courts have struck
these laws down
um as a violation of so-called trans
kids civil rights
but um I observe in the column that we
deny all kinds of of
what we might call rights to Children
routinely we don't let them work in
factories buy cigarettes buy alcohol
get married
or have sex with adults
and that's actually a long a much longer
list but uh nobody objects that it's not
fair that kids can't buy cigarettes
so I think this is a falsely framed as a
civil rights issue so I'm I'm looking at
the decision in Texas where the state
supreme court upheld the law
and that's made progressives hysterical
as usual because the default position
before this would have allowed children
to get that
gender affirming help
well there's now an entire industry
which is moving shocking numbers of
children into uh a pathway which is
almost inevitably going to lead to uh
permanent medicalization
for the rest of their lives and often uh
life-changing
irreversible and I would say mangling
surgery
so it's not a small matter it's it's uh
it's more advanced in the US and more
culturally entrenched and
then then in the UK and while especially
Continental Europe is starting to move
away from this as is maybe not the best
way to treat confused underage people
uh the for the US it's it's become a
political cause so and I think
you know I I think we're in the midst of
a major medical Scandal that we will
look back on in much the same way that
we look back on
giving people lobotomies to to solve
their mental illness I I I just think
the results are ghastly the truth is
that most
children who are unhappy with their sex
grow out of it and the main thing that
they need to do is go through puberty
and that's what gender in affirming care
won't let you do you're put on puberty
blockers and that itself is medically
highly dubious uh can lead to Bone
thinning and it uh it inhibits mental
development the puberties it may be
confusing it may be uh
often unpleasant and you know it feels
like your body's being taken over which
it is it's being taken over by adulthood
uh but it's but it's medically vital
and uh we started interfering with it
at scale without any real research on
what the consequences are and I think
that down the road we're probably going
to be looking at class action suits by a
lot of very unhappy young adults who
want to to come to some understanding as
to how they were allowed to do this or
why this was done to them
um it
we don't let children make major
decisions
uh for themselves for for a good reason
they don't know what they're doing they
haven't been around long enough
uh to to make to make life-changing
decisions of of this order
and of course a lot of the problem is
parents
so
I don't think that we should be letting
parents make these decisions on behalf
of children either
um because it's not their lives that are
at risk their ability to have children
that are risks or their ability even to
reach orgasm in adulthood
and to that point you mentioned um just
then which is the fact that if you if
you look across the world it seems as
though in Europe and UK it's like you're
retreating for somebody's positions or
at least not going us all in and I just
wondered why do you think it has become
so politicized in the US
um you know is it is it political
parties is it becoming part of a culture
or what is it that's got it to that
point
I think it's the success of civil rights
in relation to everyone else it's it's
all they could find they need you know
when you
um have been broadly successful in in
relation to race I mean not to whitewash
uh racial relations in the US but in
terms of the law
uh that that's pretty ironed out
the only the only kind of racial
discrimination that's that's legal is
affirmative action and I wouldn't do
that either
another topic
um but and and I think most of all it
was the success of the same-sex marriage
movement and and that was that stood up
in the Supreme Court so that is over so
there's nothing wrong with being gay
can't be discriminated against for being
gay so you there was just this
desperation for a new cause and I
thought it was not a coincidence that
right on the heels right on the heels of
widespread acceptance of same-sex
marriage suddenly came up this uh weird
obsession with transgenderism and
therefore a new a new population needs
protection from bigotry
and what is the argument from Lowe's
activists who you see that ruling in
Texas and as you say are appalled by it
um do you understand it at all where
they're coming from
I I am familiar with the rhetoric uh yes
it's supposedly a matter of children's
rights uh and it's uh it's they portray
these laws as
anti-lbgtqia plus uh whereas it has
nothing to do with all those other
letters it's only about the T so it
makes it seem like this is a huge
broadside on the rights of a vast number
of people whereas it concerns a much
more specific population and furthermore
they like to claim that these uh these
laws are in service of genocide
um because supposedly if you do not
provide gender affirming care to people
who identify as trans then they're going
to kill themselves and there there is no
good evidence for this
the suicide rate before and after
transition among this population is
exactly the same so getting gender
affirming care is not uh is not going to
keep people from killing themselves
anymore
um and furthermore
you know what well there's plenty of
propaganda out there claiming that up to
like 50 percent of the trans population
kills themselves this is rubbish
of
if you look at one study at Tavistock
it's a four out of fifteen thousand now
that's probably far too many I agree but
it's not 50 percent
yeah I suppose going to look back to the
point you made earlier which is about um
you know how you can imagine a world
where there's actually lots of class
actions in the future from those who
when they are children are given gender
affirming treatment and then for some of
the you know the permanent features of
that
um can then you know take action or be
very unhappy in retrospect do you think
there's also a portion of that group um
you know people who do you know children
who are given this who actually will get
to the point that they are happy they
had it and in those cases perhaps a
gender affirming treatment is what they
need or do you think it just shouldn't
really be there for for anyone until
they reach adult age
I agree they're probably going to be a
handful of people who are happy with the
results
uh
and a legislative solution is uh
crude tool honestly uh and
I can see why doctors would be
unenthusiastic about laws Banning
certain kinds of treatment and it means
that you can't be
as individual in your decisions but
they're not taking decisions
individually they're taking a blanket
approach so that they do give exactly
the same treatment to everyone
um and
that's what gender affirming care is all
right there is only one way to treat
this and that is to basically go through
the sex change
and you know I think long ago with this
phenomenon we passed the point where
it's just you know the people who are
unhappy with the sex they were born uh
are coming out of the woodwork and and
being you know because they're going to
be more accepted this is way beyond that
this is a raging social fad which is
especially taken hold in
um in schools and
the people who are most vulnerable to it
have many other mental health problems
uh may have social problems
maybe don't fit in
uh this is an instant way to get huge
amounts of attention and and as as the
expression has it affirmation who
doesn't want affirmation
and it means your parents are going to
be doting on you your teachers are going
to be doting on you if this uh
the way this is now constructed uh the
trans kids are Sanctified in a in the
social media at school
it's incredibly seductive so this
we're dealing with
a massive social contagion which is
possibly doing a lot of medical harm and
that's why I think legislation coming in
and saying this has to stop is a good
idea partly because the American Medical
Association and the American Pediatric
Academy is is all in with this stuff so
you can't count on the medical
establishment to put brakes on
and just final question and you
mentioned in your piece about Karina
Cohen I wonder if you could just tell
viewers about that case
oh criticon who now
goes by Corey
um transitioned at the age of 19 and
1994 and
he still identifies as the so-called
transsexual which is the term we used to
use
uh here accepts now that he is male and
has always been male
uh he regards his transition as
a failed fantasy
in fact he emphasizes that this is not
even about treating a mental illness it
is about
fulfilling someone's fantasy and
it's a false fantasy you can't change
sex
and I would say furthermore
what
if you do manage to change sex what have
you accomplished
just
it is not a meaningful achievement in
the world and I don't think that because
I don't believe
sex
explains Identity or should really be
the
all of your identity even if you manage
to switch signs
that's a very broad category and it
doesn't get you anywhere as a person
but this um
Corey Cohen uh is one of the people who
testified before the state legislature
uh in support of the bill and he's now
on a on a campaign
specifically to ban pediatric
transitions
[Music]
thank you
foreign